for a long time I understood nihilism
very well like I could understand its
rationale associated with the tragedy of
life associating with suffering and evil
associated with the observation of
finitude and the arbitrary and unjust
nature of the world but the more I
thought about it the less I've come to
believe that there's any excuse for it
whatsoever and I think the reason for
that is that it forced all the effort it
four stalls the ability to discover for
yourself maybe there's no reason to be
so goddamn hopeless except that it's
easier to be useless now and I not
believe me I'm not making that case I'm
not saying that that's what's besetting
people who are clinically depressed for
example that's that's not my point
clinical depression is a terrible thing
there's lots of reasons to be rendered
to be to be tossed into a catastrophic
condition that isn't what I mean I mean
that kind of cynical arrogant rational
hyper-intelligent nihilism that throws
the world away as if it's of little use
before it's been properly engaged with
better to engage with it and see what
happens and better to make the
assumption that if the world isn't
returning to you what it is that you
need then either you're not doing it
right
or you've conceptualized what you need
badly why not at least open yourself up
to that possibility right because you
could be wrong
hopefully if you're suffering this is a
great thing to know hopefully if you're
suffering you're wrong
because if you're suffering and you're
right then there's nowhere to go so it's
very useful to find out whatever errors
you might be committing another thing
that's really interesting about the Jews
in the Old Testament it's a remarkable
thing every single time they get
flattened by God it's always their fault
they never say the world that God
created was corrupt and God is evil they
never say that no matter what happens
right no matter what catastrophe occurs
when they have every reason to at least
put that hypothesis forward they
they say we erred we walked off the path
it's our fault and that's hard you know
because it puts all the weight of human
catastrophe on the human being that's
very hard but the upside is it gives you
the control it opens up the door that it
opens up the possibility that you could
be the person that could set it right if
you would just let go of what's in your
way whatever that is